*spannungsvolle Musik*
Loki, Spider-Man, der Hulk.
Nach fast 30 MCU-Filmen
sind das bekannte Charaktere.
Kennt ihr
die Alligator-Variante von Loki?
Oder den Schweine-Spider-Man
Peter Poker aka Spiderham?
Oder diese Godzilla-Variante
vom Hulk mit Schwanz?
Auch die
sind offizielle Marvel-Charaktere.
Erklärt wird ihre Existenz
durch das Multiversum.
Einer, der damit zu tun hat,
ist Dr. Strange.
Mit "Multiverse of Madness"
kommt er jetzt in die Kinos.
Ob die Idee
von unendlich vielen Universen
wahnsinnig strange
oder physikalische Wirklichkeit ist,
das checken wir jetzt.
*Marvel-Melodie*
Tag, Jack Pop hier.
Seit "Spider-Man - No Way Home"
bin ich gespannt,
wie es im MCU mit den
Paralleluniversen weitergeht.
Damals
hatte Dr. Strange aus Versehen
Risse ins Multiversum gezaubert.
Das war für die Stabilität
des Multiversums nicht geil.
Dafür führte es
zu diesem epischen Moment.
Da ist das ganze Kino ausgerastet,
ich auch.
Das war clever von Marvel,
denn wenn sich Welten überschneiden,
dann ist alles möglich im MCU.
*spannungsvolle Musik*
Weil das Marvel-Universum
superverwirrend ist,
entspannen wir, holen tief Luft.
Schauen uns eine Einordnung an
vom TikTok-Kanal NerdBase.
Hi, Karim.
Hey, danke, dass ich da sein darf.
Das Multiversum hat im MCU
eine längere Geschichte,
als die meisten glauben.
In "Thor 2" haben wir
zum 1. Mal einen Hinweis gehört.
Imagine, this is our world.
And, thank you,
this is another world.
Normally, they're separated.
But during the alignment
everything is connected.
Aber erst in "Dr. Strange 1"
hat The Ancient One
ausführlicher übers Multiversum
gesprochen.
This universe is only one
of an infinite number.
Worlds without end.
Aber das Konzept des Multiversums
ist bei Marvel nichts Neues.
Das gibt es in den Comics
seit Jahrzehnten.
1962 weiß es Johnny Storm
von den "Fantastic Four",
der in einer alternativen Realität,
einer anderen Erde, gelandet ist.
Im Multiversum gibt es zig Erden,
und das MCU
ist nur eine von vielen.
Da kann man
schnell die Übersicht verlieren.
Aber Marvel
hat ein Nummerierungssystem.
Es gibt also die Haupterde,
Erde-616,
da passiert das meiste
im Marvel-Universum.
Dann gibt es andere Erden
mit eigenen Realitäten
und eigenen Zeitlinien.
Etwa die Erde-199999,
das ist das MCU,
die Film- und Serienwelt.
Und es gibt unsere eigene Erde,
und zwar Erde-1218.
Dort kennt man Superhelden,
aber nur aus Comics,
Filmen und Serien.
Danke, Karim.
Das Marvel-Multiverse ist riesig
und total strange.
Die Frage ist,
ob unsere Realität mithalten kann.
Wir schauen in die Wissenschaft,
die sagt,
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen,
dass wir in einem Multiversum leben.
Es gibt physikalische
und mathematische Theorien dazu.
Die 3 prominentesten
schauen wir uns an.
Für die 1. Theorie
machen wir nichts Abgefahrenes,
sondern schauen in den Nachthimmel.
Wenn wir ins Weltall sehen,
gibt es eine Grenze,
über die wir
nicht hinwegblicken können.
Man spricht
vom beobachtbaren Universum.
Wie eine riesige Kugel um die Erde,
über die wir
nicht hinausschauen können.
Das liegt an 2 Dingen.
An der Geschwindigkeitsobergrenze
für Information und Materie,
der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und daran, dass das Universum
einen Anfang hatte, den Urknall.
Das kosmologische Standardmodell
sagt,
dass das Universum
13,8 Mrd. Jahre alt ist.
Die maximale Strecke,
die Licht zurücklegt haben kann,
bis es bei uns ankommt,
sind 13,8 Mrd. Lichtjahre.
Alles, was weiter weg ist,
existiert höchstwahrscheinlich,
liegt aber
hinter dieser Kugelgrenze.
Wir können es nicht sehen, weil
das Licht davon keine Zeit hatte,
uns zu erreichen.
In der 1. Multiversums-Theorie
geht man davon aus,
dass es hinter der Kugelgrenze
immer weitergeht.
Dass der Weltraum
unendlich groß ist.
Das können wir
hier nicht ideal zeigen,
deshalb ein vereinfachtes Modell:
Hier ist unsere Erde
mit dem beobachtbaren Universum
als Kugel um sich herum.
In einem unendlichen großen Weltraum
bedeutet das:
Es gibt noch unendlich viele anderer
solcher beobachtbaren Universen,
die, je nach Betrachter,
einen anderen Mittelpunkt haben.
Das Multiversum
besteht laut dieser Theorie
aus unendlich
vielen beobachtbaren Universen.
Die sind räumlich
so weit voneinander entfernt,
dass sie nichts
miteinander zu tun haben können.
Aber sie haben etwas gemeinsam.
Die Naturgesetze
sind überall gleich.
Die Gravitation
oder die chemischen Elemente.
Gleiche Regeln für alle,
und das macht schon
diese 1. Theorie total strange.
Im unendlich großen Multiversum
gibt es unendlich oft die Chance,
dass sich ein Planet bildet,
der so aussieht wie unsere Erde.
Auf dem sich Leben
so entwickelt wie bei uns.
Das bedeutet,
dass es irgendwo da draußen
eine exakte Kopie
von mir gegen muss.
That's hilarious.
Das klingt verrückt
und ist schwer vorstellbar.
Aber wissenschaftlich
ist das nicht unplausibel,
man kann es sogar ausrechnen.
In einem
unendlich großen Multiversum
gibt es nur eine endliche Anzahl
an möglichen Teilchenkombinationen.
Deshalb haben
Forschende ausgerechnet,
wie groß der Abstand zwischen
2 exakt gleichen Menschen ist.
Ergebnis:
Dich gibt es alle ...
*gefühlvolle Musik*
Shit!
Aber was heißt das fürs MCU?
Wenn diese 1. Multiversums-Theorie
stimmt,
dann spricht es für ein Multiversum,
wie es Marvel präsentiert.
Mit verschiedenen Varianten
von ein und demselben Charakter,
die unterschiedliche
Persönlichkeit haben.
Ein bisschen strange ist nur,
dass Dr. Strange
auch überall Dr. Strange heißt.
Dr. Strange, not Master Strange,
not Mr. Strange, Dr. Strange.
Während die 1. Multiversums-Theorie
noch moderate Annahmen macht,
wird es in Theorie 2 schon wilder.
Sie heißt "Ewige Inflation"
und hat damit zu tun,
dass unser beobachtbares Universum,
die Kugel, von der wir sprachen,
keine fest Größe hat,
sondern sich permanent ausdehnt.
Wir müssen unsere Aussage von vorhin
revidieren.
Es stimmt,
Licht hatte 13,8 Mrd. Jahre Zeit,
uns zu erreichen, aber das ist
nicht der Radius dieser Kugel.
Der ist eigentlich viel größer,
nämlich 46 Mrd. Lichtjahre,
in jede Richtung.
Das liegt an dieser Ausdehnung.
Wichtig dabei ist, die Ausdehnung
läuft nicht gleich schnell ab.
Man geht davon aus,
dass es kurz nach dem Urknall
eine Phase gab,
in der sich das Universum
extrem schnell ausgedehnt hat.
Diese Phase nennt man Inflation.
Und mit der Inflation
sind die Naturkonstanten
stehen geblieben oder eingefroren.
Also haben den Wert erhalten,
den sie heute noch haben.
Und es ist gut,
dass sie so eingefroren sind,
denn wenn sie
nur minimal anders wären,
ganz gering abweichen würden
vom heutigen Wert,
hätte es uns Menschen
womöglich nie gegeben.
Das Universum hätte nie
die Bildung von Atomen zugelassen.
Holy shit!
Für die Theorie,
auf die wir hinauswollen,
bedeutet das, es ist vorstellbar:
Dass diese Inflation
in den meisten Bereichen
des Weltraums
nie aufgehört hat und weiterläuft.
Deswegen heißt die Theorie
"Ewige Inflation".
Um euch das schmackhaft zu machen,
habe ich ein Beispiel mitgebracht.
Kuchen.
Lasst uns den Kuchen
im Backofen beobachten,
wo er auf den 1. Blick
gleichmäßig aufgeht.
Unser Kuchen ist der Weltraum,
in dem die Inflation abläuft.
Es gibt aber im Kuchen
kleine Gasbläschen,
in denen die Inflation
aufgehört hat.
Hier dehnt sich alles
nur langsam aus.
In einem Gasbläschen
ist z.B. unser Universum
mit seinen Naturkonstanten.
Es gibt aber nicht nur ein Bläschen,
sondern mehrere.
Wenn der Kuchen unendlich groß wäre,
was ich begrüßen würde,
gäbe es auch
unendlich viele Gasbläschen.
Und damit unendlich viele Universen.
Fertig ist das Multiversum.
Guten Appetit.
Es gibt eine Sache,
die uns den Appetit verdirbt.
In den verschiedenen Gasbläschen
hat die Inflation
zu verschiedenen Zeitpunkten
aufgehört.
Die Naturkonstanten
sind in verschiedenen Momenten
eingefroren.
Können von Universum zu Universum
unterschiedlich sein.
Das hat Auswirkungen
auf alle Gesetzmäßigkeiten
innerhalb der Universen.
Die können komplett anders aussehen.
Alle Regeln, die darin gelten,
können unterschiedlich sein.
Das bedeutet,
dass alles möglich ist.
Jede Art von Universum,
die ihr euch vorstellen könnt,
kann existieren.
Unser bekanntes Universum.
Ein lebensfeindliches Universum
ohne komplexe Materie.
Ein Universum mit 4 oder mehr
räumlichen Dimensionen.
Ein Universum komplett aus Käse.
Ein Universum,
in dem dieses Video nicht von uns,
sondern von einem Dino gedreht wird.
*Fauchen*
Das kommt nah ran an das,
was im 1. Teil von Dr. Strange
erzählt wird.
Worlds without end.
Some benevolent and life-giving.
Others filled
with malice and hunger.
Was für ein Universum
würdet ihr gut finden?
Schreibt in die Kommentare.
Die Möglichkeit,
dass Universen komplett
unterschiedlich sein könnten,
ist auch ein Problem.
Wenn irgendwo
andere Naturgesetzt gelten,
und wir das Universum betreten,
könnte es passieren,
dass unsere Atome nicht wissen,
was sie machen sollen.
Sie zerfallen oder zerstrahlen.
Das muss Dr. Strange
im Hinterkopf haben,
wenn er mit seinen Portalen
andere Universen besuchen will.
Erst checken, ob seine Atome
das anderen Universum abkönnen.
Die ersten 2 Theorien
waren schon strange.
Es gibt aber
noch ein kontroverseres Modell.
Das hat mit dieser Szene zu tun
aus "Infinity War".
What was that?
I went forward in time.
To view alternate futures.
To see all the possible outcomes
of the conflict.
How many did you see?
14.000.605.
How many we win?
One.
Dr. Strange macht quasi
ein Reise durch Paralleluniversen.
Aber nicht als Reise durch den Raum,
sondern als Reise
durch alternative Realitäten.
Diesen Ansatz hat Marvel
in der Loki-Serie vertieft.
Auch die setzt sich
mit den Wirrungen des Multiversums
auseinander.
Aber nicht als Betrachtung
eines unendlichen Weltraums.
Sondern hier wirkt es so,
als würden alle Parallelwelten
nah beieinander existieren.
In der Serie trifft Loki
verschiedene Varianten
von sich selbst.
Es wird erklärt,
wie die zustande kommen.
Durch sogenannte Nexus-Events.
Das sind Entscheidungen,
deren Konsequenzen so weitreichend,
so weltverändernd sind,
dass sich danach
ein Paralleluniversum bildet.
In dem sind die Konsequenzen
neue Realität.
Nach dieser Logik hätte Dr. Strange
14.000.604 Paralleluniversen
erzeugen können.
Das ist der Grundgedanke
der 3. Theorie.
Die heißt "Viele-Welten-Theorie"
und beruht auf der Idee,
dass alle Entscheidungen
und Handlungen
alternative Realitäten erzeugen.
Und damit
Paralleluniversen aufmachen.
Ihren Ursprung
hat sie in der Quantenmechanik.
Laut Quantenmechanik
können Elementarteilen,
die kleinsten bekannten Teilchen,
verschiedene Zustände
gleichzeitig haben.
Das klingt strange,
weil wir das auf makroskopischer
Ebene nie erleben.
Bei den Teilchen trifft es zu.
Ihr kennt das berühmte Beispiel:
Schrödingers Katze.
Die ist in der Kiste
und gleichzeitig tot und lebendig,
so lange,
bis wir in die Kiste schauen.
Dann ist die Katze
entweder tot oder lebendig.
Das klingt,
als würde das In-die-Kiste-schauen
den Prozess vereinfachen,
aber das stimmt nicht.
Was ist
mit dem anderen Zustand passiert?
Den, den wir nicht sehen.
Das ist bis heute nicht geklärt.
Es gibt
verschiedene Interpretationen
der Gesetze der Quantenmechanik.
Die 1. ist die Kopenhagener Deutung.
Die haben Niels Bohr und
Werner Heisenberg 1929 formuliert.
Laut der
kollabieren bei einer Messung
alle Zustände bis auf einen,
der unsere Realität bildet.
Wenn wir in die Kiste schauen
und die Katze lebendig ist,
dann ist der anderen Zustand,
in dem sie tot ist, verschwunden.
Das ist die Deutung,
die als Standardinterpretation gilt.
Ist aber nicht die einzige.
1957 hat der Physiker Hugh Everett
die Viele-Welten-Interpretation
aufgestellt.
Laut der passiert was anderes.
Die Zustände kollabieren nicht,
sondern stattdessen
spaltet sich das Universum auf.
Jeder einzelne Zustand wird
in einer eigenen Welt angenommen.
Für die Katze heißt das,
wenn wir reinschauen und sehen,
dass die Katze lebt, ist
ein Paralleluniversum entstanden,
in dem die Katze tot ist.
Alles andere im Universum
ist gleich,
gleiche Naturgesetze.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem wir nachgeschaut haben.
Analog zur Quantenmechanik
bedeutet das:
Jede Entscheidung, die wir treffen,
führt zu neuen Universen,
in denen jede mögliche Konsequenz
Realität wird.
Wenn das stimmt,
entstehen in jeder Sekunde
unfassbar viele Paralleluniversen.
Der einzige Unterschied
ist die Entscheidung,
die wir getroffen haben.
Nach dieser Theorie ist es egal,
ob sich Dr. Strange
die 14 Mio. Varianten anschaut,
wie der Kampf gegen Thanos ausgeht.
Denn es werden eh alle stattfinden,
nur in Paralleluniversen.
Das muss frustrierend
für die Avengers sein.
Sie können nur
einen Bruchteil der Leute retten,
die sie retten wollen.
Denn wenn sie jemanden retten,
macht ein Paralleluniversum auf,
in dem die Menschen sterben.
Surprise!
Fakt ist,
die Viele-Welten-Theorie ist das,
was dem am nächsten kommt,
was Marvel uns präsentiert.
Zumindest das, was wir
bei Loki oder "What If...?" sehen.
Und den Varianten der Charaktere
in den "Dr. Strange"-Filmen.
Zum echten Multiversum
müssen wir noch sagen:
All diese Theorien
klingen fantastisch und strange,
sind aber
nicht aus der Luft gegriffen.
Sie haben ihren Ursprung
in wissenschaftlichen Beobachtungen.
Z.B. zur Inflation.
Trotzdem gibt es ein Problem:
Aktuell fehlen uns
brauchbare Methoden,
um Theorien zum Multiversum
ausreichend zu überprüfen.
Und damit zu beweisen.
Es kann sein,
dass es das Multiversum gibt,
oder dass es das nicht gibt.
Viele lehnen Theorien dazu
auch als unwissenschaftlich ab.
In der Wissenschaft geht es darum,
Dinge zu beweisen,
oder zumindest ablehnen zu können.
Solange wir das nicht haben,
bleibt uns nur übrig,
das Multiversum
mit Popcorn zu genießen.
Raucht euch der Kopf?
Es war viel Input heute.
Wir haben
einen Aspekt außen vor gelassen:
Wie das mit den Portalen
bei Dr. Strange funktioniert.
Ist es realistisch,
von Universum zu Universum
zu reisen?
Dafür sind wir
durchs YouTube-Universum gereist.
Wir haben uns zusammengetan
mit einem anderen Kanal.
Den Extracontent zum Multiversum
bringt euch bei Dr. Strange
natürlich Doktor Whatson.
*Marvel-Melodie*
Wow, ich wusste nicht,
dass du das kannst.
Ich habe mich mit Portalen
beschäftigt und bin einem drin.
Kann ich dich anfassen?
Ich probiere es besser nicht.
Wir reden über Portale
und ob es sie geben könnte.
Es geht um Weiße,
Schwarze und Wurmlöcher.
Und um Albert Einstein.
Wenn euch das interessiert,
klickt auf unser Video.
Hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Bis bald.
Den Link dazu
packe ich euch in die Infobox.
Schaut unbedingt rein.
Sagt mir, wie ihr die Folge fandet.
Lasst einen Kommentar da.
Vergesst nicht,
auf "abonnieren" zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns in diesem
oder anderem Universum wieder.
Ich würde mich freuen.
Bis dahin.
Cut!
Hallo.
Hier ist der Regisseur.
Hier oben kommt ihr zum Video
vom Kanal Doktor Whatson.
Wenn ihr im Marvel-Universum
unterwegs sein wollt,
guckt mal hier,
unsere Folge zu "Hawkeye".
Copyright MDR 2022